[Music]
my name is ani fenelli
soon i'll be an editor at the new york
times magazine your voice is simply
peerless and in six weeks i'm getting
married in a lavish but tasteful
ceremony
luke comes for money but i have
something no trust fund can buy
the edge
[Music]
love my work
hate babies
i am this close to the life no one
thought i deserved
this is ani nice to meet you
mr larson it's me
[Music]
tiffany
tiffany
[Music]
i'm working on a documentary about the
incident at your high school
there are still so many questions that
you've never answered
people want to know were you a hero
or
an accomplice
imagine what it's going to be like when
they find out about what happened
how could you not tell me about this
i carried this horrible thing with me
alone for years and it has built up this
rage inside of me
don't know what's me
and what point i invented
your former classmate has made claims
against you don't talk about what
happened that night are you seriously
trying to threaten me right now
[Applause]
you have to get into the nitty-gritty
details for the whole world
do you like your life tiffany
[Applause]
sometimes i feel like a wind-up doll
turn my key
and i will tell you exactly what you
want to hear
[Music]
you